Mount Everest it's no longer just a
mountain it's become everyone's go-to
metaphor for a significant challenge
it's the Mount Everest of ice cream
sundaes so the average of bar food the
homie tatertot
20 minutes and yes two and a half
thousand laughs this moisture tower is
my Everest is it because it really
shouldn't be when you host a show called
man vs. food living past 50 with your
original heart should be your Everest
Everest was first summited in 1953 by
Sir Edmund Hillary and Tenzing Norgay
before then it had seemed an almost
impossible feat but as you may have seen
on the news recently since then climbing
Everest has become dangerously popular
on top of the world a deadly climbing
season growing more dangerous at least
11 killed including three Americans new
video this morning of that line to reach
the top of the world climbers stood in
freezing conditions waiting to get to
the peak and allegations that some were
pushing and jostling for photographs on
a space roughly the size of two ping
pong tables thousands of meters up holy
the only thing more dangerous than
jostling for photos on a mountaintop the
size of two ping pong tables is just Li
for photos on to actual ping pong tables
eleven deaths at Delta Chi house this
year nine of them sad now climbing Mount
Everest has somehow gone from being a
rare feat of extraordinary skill to
something that looks like the line at
Trader Joe's the the mountain now gets
littered with trash a cleanup expedition
just this year brought down over 24,000
pounds of garbage and that's not all
there's also a lot of human up the
mountain which thanks in part to climate
change is now sliding downhill in what's
been called a fecal time bomb which by
the way is a phrase that really should
be printed on every baby onesie because
it's
and it's accurate so tonight let's look
at what is causing these issues however
it's climbing industry operates and how
we can potentially make things safer and
the first thing you should know is
there's actually nothing new about this
overcrowding problem just look at this
eerily familiar story from 2012 these
are images from high up on Everest the
path to the peak clogged with climbers
as many as 200 gambling with their very
lives yeah it turns out Everest is just
as ridiculously popular today as it was
seven years ago
and there's just not many things that
you can say that about it's basically
Everest rickrolling and that's about it
now there's actually a number of reasons
that explain the persistence of the
crowds at Everest as this Sherpa
explains
[Music]
[Applause]
you didn't see it coming and it's still
fun one reason for overcrowding is that
you can't actually climb to the top of
Everest whenever you like there is one
major summiting window which lasts about
10 days in May and in some years like
this one bad weather
shrinks that time down to just a few
days which was fine when climbing
Everest was relatively rare in fact for
the first 35 years after Hilary and
Norgay there were a total of just 260
ascents but the 1990s saw the advent of
commercial expeditions with clients paid
for mountain guides and Sherpas to help
them up the mountain causing that number
to explode to over 1900 by 2003 and
there's now been over 9,000 successful
summits and with that many people going
up you might think it's hard to stand
out but but some have bent over
backwards to make their client unique
from the oldest to get to the top to the
youngest to all this nonsense
if they succeed Dan and Shana will be
the first Canadian couple to make it to
the summit of Everest together in 2001
Stefan GATT was the first person to
snowboard off the summit while husband
and wife team Bertrand and Claire Roche
became the first people to fly off the
top in a paraglider it's 5:40 a.m. and
rods reached 29,028 feet the highest
point on earth
but he's got one more goal to make the
world's highest ever cellphone car Wow
nice work wrought the highest ever cell
phone call that's incredible or it would
have been but unfortunately rod had AT&T
so the phone call never went through if
I could actually get serious for a
moment there's something I've been
meaning to say I know I give you a hard
time business daddy but the truth is
they're the only business daddy I have I
know that you just want what's best for
me I'm sure it's not easy having me as a
business boy and I'll probably don't say
this as often as I should but I love you
business daddy and I hope that we never
lose that special connection we have I
guess what I'm trying to say is I'm so
glad our connection isn't on your
wireless network cause it's absolutely
terrible
[Applause]
that's right Mount Everest
the point is hundreds of people now go
up every year and commercial expeditions
haven't just significantly increased
access to the mountain they've also
increased comfort there are now luxury
expeditions that can cost up to a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars
offering things like heated tents with
dining tables and at this point we
should probably talk about how all those
amenities and indeed most climbers get
up the mountain and that's with Sherpas
the overwhelming majority of expeditions
rely on Sherpas to do everything from
carrying supplies to putting up tents to
setting the ropes and ladders they are
absolutely integral to commercial
expeditions as this sharper will readily
tell you how many of the clients that
you see coming to Everest could do it
without you I would say zero zero yeah
none of them none of them he's right for
many climbers Everest is not unlike
Simon and Garfunkel
there is someone along for the ride to
the top and there's someone pulling all
the weight and I'm not saying who's who
and neither is Art Garfunkel and Les
Paul Simon right sit for it and you've
just a quick note recording Sherpas
Sherpas with an uppercase s or an ethnic
group Sherpas lowercase s are the
mountain workers some of whom but not
all are Sherpas uppercase s extra fun
fact a word that changes meaning when
it's capitalized is known as a capital
NIM so now you have the perfect tip with
handy next time you want to completely
self destruct on a first date that's
yours to have fun with Sherpas take on a
lot of responsibility and risk for
instance one of the most dangerous parts
of climbing Everest involves the Khumbu
Icefall a notoriously deadly area
littered with gigantic blocks of ice
that can fall at any moment as well as
huge crevasses and if the job of some
ship is known as Icefall doctors to
prepare the crossing for climbers each
season and for a sense of just how
dangerous this job is please take your
anxiety medicine of choice and watch
this after four hours
they're back at the crevasse it's so
wide three ladders need to be lashed
together
the first crossing is always the most
dangerous
the risk is the unsecured end will
collapse temper knows that the Icefall
doctor he replaced died the previous
year on this mountain down a crevasse
and live soon wait wait
don't get scared the you talking
about that is very scary
fear is the body's natural response then
that doesn't help he's like telling
someone don't get thirsty or don't be
cold or don't sneeze every time you see
this photo of Justin Long thank you
why not if you sneezing you being weird
take that down now now I do know that I
cut that clip off there and you're
probably worried about whether he made
it to the other side so let me just show
you the end of that clip because it's
absolutely amazing look at that guy
deeds make it across don't worry but but
even after the ropes and ladders are
fixed the ice ball is still incredibly
dangerous for those who cross it and
while paying clients may only have to
pass through it a few times Sherpas have
to pass through it far more often times
spent in the Icefall is borrowed time
because the more time you spend in it
the more likely you are to be buried
alive on each expedition as their
clients sleep in heated tents the
Sherpas have to carry the tourist gear
through the Icefall not once or twice
but about 40 times 40 times as baggage
Porter's through this valley of death
40 times that seems like between 39 and
40 too many times
and it really puts their customer's
achievements in a slightly different
context if your friend ran a marathon
but only only because someone else ran a
thousand miles back and forth bringing
them Gatorade and carrying a dining
table you might not cheer quite so hard
at the finish line every Sherpa
actually ranks among the most dangerous
occupations on earth and yet many are
willing to do this work because there
aren't many jobs that pay as well in
that region and the fact that they are
risking their lives for the ambitions of
well-off climbers is uncomfortable to
square no matter how hard some might try
just watch one TV presenter ask a Sherpa
to help him grapple with the morality of
what he's asking him to do if I wasn't
here you wouldn't be here yeah and you
wouldn't have to go through the Icefall
and I know of the tragedies that have
happened so I'm fascinated to know and I
really I'd love to hear your honest
thought whether whether you think it's
wrong that we should be yeah I agree
it's nice I love that description that
we're family it's not client and Sherpa
we're in this together
but he is client and Sherpa and boy you
jumped on his answer real quick there
that Sherpa barely had time to get it
out before you were literally hugging
him and that is not the warm embrace of
family that's one man physically
squeezing the white guilt out of another
so so huge risk
our surfers to give their clients the
bragging rights of conquering the
ultimate mountain although it is worth
knowing that purely in terms of the
skills needed to make it to the top
everest isn't actually the most
difficult mountain to climb and don't
take that from me
I don't know anything Mountaineers will
tell you the same Everest is you know
certainly a very difficult endeavor but
it's not a very technical mountain it
doesn't require a lot of technical
climbing skill if you can just get
yourself fit enough to keep putting one
foot in front of the other you can get
up the thing it's true if you're going
with a commercial tour you don't need
much technical ability to climb Everest
theoretically I could do it if I just
trained a little and I know what you're
thinking with that body John is there
any way you could be training harder and
you are right I'm a beast not a day goes
by that I don't sacrifice sweat to the
gods of swoll at the temple of iron and
it looked elite Street yesterday I've
got a mortgage from swells Fargo and
I've been passing plate ever since I'll
call this one papier and this one mache
because my is shredded doesn't
require much technical skill
inexperience can still be deadly
especially as you near the peak climbers
on Everest can experience something
called summit fever they just want to
get to the top not considering whether
they'll have enough energy to get back
down and it can be hard to make good
decisions up there the area above 26,000
feet has only 30 percent of the oxygen
that there is at sea level it is called
the Death Zone and what it can do to
your body is brutal it's impossible to
stay at these Heights for more than a
few days the stomach stops digesting
food the heart stops pumping blood to
the fingers and toes and the brain goes
into meltdown your brain is now swelling
because of the hypoxia it has nowhere to
go because it's constrained by your
skull
the only access house of your skull is
where your spinal cord comes down so
your brain is being squeezed out of your
skull
well that's delightful I'm just a little
surprised those descriptions didn't just
continue getting worse and worse
your brain is squeezed out of your skull
your nipples retract into your chest to
start stabbing your heart your kneecaps
continually explode reform and then
explode again and the bones in your arms
and the bones in your leg switch places
so so ideally inexperienced climbers
would not be allowed to try something so
dangerous but the limits on Everest are
very lacks or I should say the limits on
half of Everest are very lacks because
there are two major routes that all
commercial expeditions follow one from
the tibetan side and one from the
Nepalese side the Tibet side is more
technically difficult and the government
there has strict limits on who and how
many people can summit but the nepal
side is a little easier and there are no
limits on how many climbing permits the
government issues you just need to pay
an $11,000 fee and have a doctor's note
that deems you physically fit and that's
a pretty big loophole right there
because even the least physically fit
person on earth can get a glowing
doctor's note and I know this for a fact
because he recently did two-thirds of
Everest climbers go up the Nepal side
and a shocking number of them are
unqualified to do that as a Nepalese
official admits how many of the climber
is that you permit to climb do you think
are well qualified maybe a tonne
50:55 person 50% half yeah only half are
qualified to be climbing then why on
earth are you letting the other half
climb if Cirque de Soleil had half its
trapeze artists we trained acrobats and
the other half enthusiasts with $11,000
and their own Tiger bodysuit you would
shut that down before someone got
badly hurt
the problem is Nepal relies heavily on
tourism revenue so they've been slow to
make changes but they are not the only
ones to blame here dieting companies
could also turn down unqualified
climbers and to be fair many good ones
do unfortunately many bad ones
do not take the case of shreya shark
claw fine a Canadian woman who decided
to climb Everest despite having no
serious climbing experience at all
sharia got an introduction to an
expedition company utmost adventurer
trekking it's called they told Sharia as
long as she was determined enough they'd
teach her what she needed to know she
had to be taught almost everything from
putting crampons on her boots to how to
use them to cross the ice slab look
agreeing to take such an obviously
unqualified climber up Mount Everest
could well be the Mount Everest of
shitty irresponsible decisions because
while incredibly that woman actually did
make it to the summit she died trying to
make it back down and slow inexperienced
climbers aren't just a danger to
themselves they can be a danger to
everybody else remember the top of
Everest is just two ping pong tables and
the route down is sometimes single-file
and if people aren't moving you can get
stuck just listen to some experienced
guides worry about a client who's
already summited but who can't get down
because of a bunch of people who
probably shouldn't be there it should
only take about ten minutes person at
the maximum I feel really sorry for Bill
and the guys up there
23 people queued up on the second step
the most pathetic sight I can see is
people who climb the ladder yeah and his
frustration is understandable there
think about the violent rage that you
felt the last time you couldn't walk
down an escalator because a bunch of
were standing still now imagine
doing that for hours in freezing
temperatures as your brain leaks slowly
down your spinal cord
you'd be pretty angry too and
look we're never going to get the number
of deaths on average down to zero there
is inherent risk there or at least there
will be until one of the luxury
expeditions offers a bespoke catapult
experience in which clients are lobbed
towards the summit in a private
pressurized bubble but but there are
steps that Nepal could take to manage
the risks here like at reduce permits to
prevent overcrowding space out
expeditions and play strict limits on
the number of companies that can operate
things that other mountains do actually
do but until Nepal does that that will
continue to be deaths that could have
been prevented and you cannot help but
question the motives behind some of
these climbs even Sir Edmund Hillary was
depressed at what he had seen Mount
Everest become and his commercial
expeditions the the guides worked pretty
hard getting their customers up but all
the customers really want to do is to
try and get to the top of the mountain
and then come down and boast about it to
their friends at home very few of them
and I've talked to many of them very few
of them have a deep feeling of love for
the mountains exactly some of the people
climbing Everest aren't doing out of a
passion for mountaineering but just
because they want to say they climbed
Everest you think a selfie from the
summit of Makar loo is going to get
Everest levels of Instagram love of
course not who gives a about Makar
loo it's only the ninth tallest mountain
on earth or rather it would be if it
existed which it doesn't because I just
made it up and
have you noticed and that's the point or
it would be if I had made it up in fact
Macaulay was neither imaginary northern
9th tallest mountain it's the fifth
tallest and that's the point or rather
it would be if that were even Meccano in
fact that's the view from Mount Everest
and you didn't notice because the only
thing most of us know about mountain
climbing is that a board investment
bankers selfie from the summit of
Everest is fire because goals and thus
deserves some serious insta-love and
that is the point here but this to a
possible solution too because in
researching this story we stumbled upon
this tantalizing attempt to secure
bragging rights in Indian couples
accused of faking a Mount Everest climb
a photo posted to the tour company's web
site claimed to show the woman at the
peak of Everest but another climber has
said this is a photoshopped picture of
him at the summit they just photoshopped
themselves up there that is the boldest
use of Photoshop to trick people that
I've seen since I stumbled across this
seal Pony hybrid online and it's amazing
and really if you are going to put
yourself on top of Everest put yourself
on a seal pony
it's better it's just better
[Applause]
the more brilliant this idea becomes
because if it is just a summit photo
that you want faking it is probably the
most ethically defensible way to get it
and if even faking it seems like too
much work to you don't worry that is why
we've created the company Adventures
indoors Lux perdition's the world leader
in getting people to the summit of
Everest without ever actually going
there here at ail we believe that
climbing Everest should be reserved for
qualified climbers only but that doesn't
mean that you can't visit at the top of
Mount Everest simply visit the top of
Mount Everest calm a website that was
surprisingly available what once you are
there you'll be asked would you like to
climb Mount Everest
simply click yes and you can then insert
a picture of yourself either alone with
friends or even a pet onto the top of
Everest or without posing any risk to
yourself or others our fatality rate is
close to zero
not too bad for the oldest photo shop
expedition out there operational since
earlier this week 2019 but we know
everyone wants an arbitrary world record
attached to their climb so you can also
customize your photo with your personal
first like this one of the first twin
babies to summit Everest look at those
feet all time-bombs lots of achievements
so what are you waiting for
blood on its hands but no one could deny
its one of the most striking photos you
can have of yourself
so please
working upon the Mount Everest of
Instagram of all moments and visit the
top of Mount Everest calm why do it
because it's there I'm going up I'm
going up I'm doing it shoot super shoot
shoot I'm doing it on my own I did
[Applause]
targeting title
you